right much has been said in recent weeks
regarding buccaneers defensive tackle
gerald mccoy much has been said about
him much has been speculated about
whether or not he could be traded
whether or not the buccaneers would
actually cut him mccoy hasn't said much
as he's been away from off-season
workouts he broke his silence over the
weekend on social media here he is
cinco de mayo
everybody out
probably getting ready to go drink
probably drink it right now
don't matter
anyone question me that's what i do in
cinco de mayo i work
i work oh
and
i got my kids with me how many people
doing that
all pro online off the field
want to question me the heck
is he going to be ready do he love
football
what
joe mccoy laying it down and look here's
the thing i if if he wants to be with
the buccaneers he should be at offseason
workouts because
if you're gonna work out you may as well
take the insurance policy that goes
along with it he's got 13 million
dollars riding on the possibility that
in that ramshackle gym where he's
working out he injures himself he can't
play this year they don't have to pay
him if you're going to suffer a fluke
injury suffer it at the team facility
this isn't about voluntary or
involuntary this is about free insurance
that goes along with being at the team
facility if you're going to be out there
busting your butt i'm glad he's working
hard i just worry about that risk chris
blown achilles popped acl whatever the
case may be buy buy 13 million dollars
you don't know i think it's a it's a
fair point mike that you bring up i mean
that certainly he is risking a lot there
yes if he gets hurt on his own time uh
they can make a big stink about it and
take money away or not pay him money
whatever it may be but he's not happy
right now and he doesn't want to give
the organization his services for
you know not being there you know as far
as or he doesn't want to give he wants
to figure out what the future entails
he's here he's hearing oh i might not be
on the roster i might be traded he
doesn't know where that's going and the
other thing is this
we shouldn't question guys like gerald
mccoy though and a lot of the veteran
players that we see missing you know
voluntary workouts and things like that
you know again gerald mccoy where the
point he is in his career right it's
nine years in the nfl he understands
what it takes to be ready for an nfl
football season also with guys like this
odell beckham jr gerald mccoy who have
proven that they are successful and know
what it takes to be successful in the
nfl you know yeah they have a little
money in their pocket too so a lot of
the times yeah they're willing to pay a
few extra dollars to have their own
personal trainer instead of one guy
who's training 90 players and all
different positions and trying to piece
together workouts this way to where yeah
the guys who have earned their stripes
and made a little money they go no screw
you i know what i need to do to train
and i'm going to get a guy that
specifically makes me good at my
position so that's also the battle
that's fought sometimes with with these
type of players in these scenarios mike
and i think also there's a business
angle to it because even though the
salary is 13 million it's not guaranteed
and what could happen to a guy like
gerald mccoy he shows up he puts in the
work and then a week or two before the
start of the regular season they come to
him and they say we want to pay you six
and a half million instead of 13. and if
you don't take that pay cut you're gone
good luck finding someone else who'll
pay you six and a half million dollars
two weeks before the start of the season
and and i think that he probably is
looking for certainty financial
certainty whether it comes from a trade
to a new team or the buccaneers saying
here's a deal where you know what you're
going to get this year and we are
committed to you and we still want you
to be part of team i mean bruce erins
has openly talked about how as a guy
gets older the skills start to diminish
the money goes up at some point you have
to make that very tough and ruthless and
dispassionate decision to say we're just
moving on to somebody who is younger and
cheaper that's the way the system is in
the nfl it may not seem fair to the guy
who's been around for a while that's
just the way it is though chris no it is
it's the way it is and he's hitting that
fine line of yes it's
nine years in the nfl going into year 10
he's making 13 million dollars a year
yes is he worth that you know injuries
things like that the body's starting to
get beat up he's had little issues like
that over the last few years so i think
all that comes into play
i think when all said and done though
he's still gonna be in tampa or at least
playing for at least one more year i
really do i'd be shocked i mean i just
again he's still really good football
player i'm not gonna say he's one of the
best defensive tackles in the nfl
anymore but he is still really good and
i look at todd bowles at defense and
just go well you know there's not you
know a ton of difference makers in the
interior d line i think they would want
to get bruce aryans and todd balls off
on on a good foot in their first year in
the nfl or with the tampa bay buccaneers
and would want to keep a guy like mccoy
around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports